good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast and happy
Tuesday I apologize for the delayed
episode but trust and believe it is
worth it because your girl is home I am
home I've been in Florida this last week
and I love Florida but I love my family
and there's nothing in this world I love
more than my family except my bed and I
have returned to my bed I am so happy
yeah I'm sorry I said it I love Olivia I
love her house but and her bed is great
it's not my bed
got it well we're happy to have you back
I'm happy that we're happy to have you
back well I mean you kicked me off the
podcast the last two episodes
you could have done it I didn't have any
conflict I couldn't do Monday's episode
and I told you that weeks ago because I
had a doctor's appointment so I did need
a sub and then but you're like Friday
Ben Monday Olivia bye I was like oh okay
I'm using your studio and I'm taking
over your house bye oh
let's go there okay ready first of all I
gave you a day off you're welcome
I'm not complaining but I just want like
it the people to know because they
probably assumed like oh Jackie couldn't
do the episode Friday so Claudia subbed
well you obviously didn't listen to my
episode with Ben where I said you know
what I'm in Florida no and you gave me
studio
give Jackie a day off no I did listen to
it so why would you say that I said
anything else I didn't say that you said
something else I said people might think
and even though you said I'm giving her
day off they might have thought like oh
because she couldn't do it you know what
if you couldn't do it you're literally
the most pregnant [__] I've ever seen
like that's fine it's fine you can't do
it I know but some days I really can't
do it so I just wanted people to know
like I got the boot from my own show you
got the book for your own show but for
um you know what and I got the boot from
a barefooted foot you did Ben who did
you write out with his big shoeless
hairy foot and he just got to stomp over
everyone around with his big dick yeah
he really did but then yesterday I
couldn't do it Olivia did it I watched
you guys this episode that was so fun
and I do have to report you know I got
two days off of alarm free living and I
woke up earlier than ever
good even today we're recording later
woke up like got up way before my alarm
would have gone off yeah
so you love to see that
well
you're welcome I also we had taken apart
your Florida Studio before when we like
ran back to New York to get to your
doctor we were like thinking maybe we'll
podcast from your bed we took everything
apart we tried to set up a studio when I
was gonna do bed rest in Florida I
brought my studio equipment down to my
bed is what you're trying to say we
haven't been back to your house since
then so your podcast Studio was in
disarray so I didn't take over your
studio I put it back together [__]
you're welcome I carried all that
equipment up those stairs about yourself
no with Ben I was gonna say Ben didn't
help you he was literally there he did
but like it was a lot of stuff and I
didn't want to make two trips like I had
to carry stuff he had to carry stuff no
I appreciate it I love seeing the
flamingos I love seeing you in my house
I love seeing my house oh and I I was
such a good sister I went through you oh
my gosh you guys
and honestly when I saw how many
packages you out I'm like you have a
problem no but you open them no okay I
finished my sentence I just like can't
I said when I saw the amount of packages
I was like this girl has a problem I'm
seriously I'm gonna get a therapist and
like do an intervention like this is an
abnormal amount of boxes I know you've
been gone for months but like my God how
much does she order and when I tell you
there was probably 50 boxes and three of
them were things you actually ordered uh
everything else was like PR and toe
sponsors and just like product yeah I I
judged you and I was wrong I'm sorry
well it's okay because you did open my
packages keep the things that I needed
and discard of the boxes which was the
kind of thing that you could do for me
so I don't have to walk home and into
all of it I by the way like I know the
feeling like I just got home I was gone
since Wednesday I have so many boxes
outside my front door and like it's the
worst thing ever like all the work
waiting for you so honestly I know what
a good deed it was and the way that I
have taken that off your plate like not
to make everything about me like I feel
good like for doing that I'm so happy
that you feel good and I feel good
because you raided my closet while you
were Barta I did and honestly you've
never looked better
yeah I uh didn't pack anything for
Florida because I have like a bunch of I
have all my makeup down there I have all
my hair products I have like a decent
amount of clothing it's nothing like
gorgeous but it's good stuff for
podcasting and like walking around the
neighborhood
um so when we went out to dinner I
didn't have anything and I was like
there's a gorgeous closet let me go see
what my stylish you know invested
investor sister has for me and I had
such a good time you know scrolling down
the aisles of your closet picking things
I looked gorgeous I wore a very
controversial pair of shoes thank you
for being so generous so open with me I
truly appreciate you know I always have
you guys are always so surprised when I
literally would give you the shirt off
my back and lend you my nicest things
but I like it so true I'd like to see my
sisters looking nice it's true I'm just
like always like I picked up a purse and
I'm like I'm gonna wear this LOL and you
were like no you could wear it I'm like
what I can wear this Gucci bag that I
don't think I've ever seen you wear like
but I did wear new no I didn't wear it
it's relatively new but I wore it in the
same outfit that you did that was funny
you really are a generous Queen like
it's you it's I don't know why it's
shocking I enjoy a nice person I don't
know why it's shocking but like it is
and I think it's because like you really
care about like you take such good care
of like your clothes and your bags and
you have pieces for years and like
they're important to you where it's like
I throw my clothes in a ball and it's
all from Amazon like your your things
are so important important to you you
have such pride in them that I wouldn't
be mad or surprised if you were very
territorial with them but whenever any
sister like needs something you're
always like take it no take it you're so
that could never be me like you will
give someone a shirt or a bag or
whatever that you haven't even worn yet
which is crazy yeah if they needed it
and it was like the right thing for the
occasion and my sister is gonna like
step out into the world feeling and
looking her best yeah but maybe it's
shocking because like as kids that was
pretty much the only thing we ever
thought about was like somebody wearing
someone's shirt without permission like
clothes we were so territorial over them
um
yeah maybe or like as kids like we were
all
I don't know maybe like slobs and you
didn't know if you were like gonna get
your things back but now it's like you
want to ruin my dress like you'll go get
it dry cleaned
hubs that's true even though I am still
a slob I do feel like maybe now is a
good time to mention I did borrow
um this like green Abercrombie set it
was like crazy it was not expensive and
I went to Outback Steakhouse and ate a
bloom and onion it was so oily there was
like two drops of oil on the shirt and
like I don't know how to get rid of it
it's fine
if that outfit like vanished from my
closet I don't know if I would ever
notice okay it's not like one of your
prized possessions no but so you know
how sometimes like you'll think of a
clothing item that you once owned and
you're like of course I didn't ever get
rid of it but I've never I haven't seen
it in years there are things that come
into my closet never to be seen again
yeah I wonder where those things are
maybe it's like your sister stained it
with a blooming onion and it just
stashed it in the incinerator yeah it's
like one of those Mysteries of the
universe yeah like I think of certain
like t-shirts or something I'm like I
never threw that away or donated it so
like where the hell is it I know that
happened like I'll wake up in the middle
of the night
and just like be thinking about a random
piece of clothing I bought three years
ago that I never wore yeah
um we've got a great show today we've
got stories Galore and I can't wait to
talk to you about it but I did want to
mention how we kind of I believe it was
on Friday where Ben was on the toast and
we were talking about Francia Raisa and
I was telling Ben that Francia Reese has
actually a really good friend of Josh
Peck and they should get her on the
podcast and Ben was like oh let me ask
and you know everything just happened so
easily for Ben yesterday they recorded
with Francia but you said that's why
they usually release their episodes on
Monday of the good guys podcast but
today they really this week they
released it on Tuesday because they
wanted to squeeze in this um episode
with Francia and actually listened in
while they were recording because I just
was like so interested and I wasn't
doing anything else and you gotta listen
to it it's out now you can watch it on
YouTube or you can listen to it as a
podcast she was really
um very open and I think a lot of people
will enjoy the episode one just like
she's a cool fun young funny pretty girl
and she's really talented and she's like
an interesting background but then of
course you know they do up deep into the
kidney gate and she's clearing some
things up okay I will be listening
obviously I want to know all about her
and her story and kidney gate yeah it
was it was very interesting leave it to
Ben and Josh just like stumble into you
know the most premium guest of the year
right of course only the best for the
good guys and she also talked a lot
about like the ins and outs of being a
kidney genre one thing I learned from
her episode which I found to be so
interesting
is that if you are somebody who has
given someone a kidney and years later
or however much time later your
remaining kidney fails or something
happens and you end up needing a
transplant because you were a donor you
automatically go to the top of the list
wow I mean I know it makes sense because
it's like you are missing a kidney
because you gave one you gave it yeah
but
do some people just get their kidney out
and then go on with one kidney yeah
everyone does you only need one kidney
to live right so then this is gonna
sound so dumb the people who like need a
kidney transplant do they lose both
kidneys no it's a good question I was
actually thinking about that or maybe
the other kidney isn't strong enough yes
yes yes but like a healthy person
in this life only needs one kidney to
survive and the problem is is like I
think one is really essentially supposed
to be a backup for the other
yeah but if they're both not operating
at 100 then you do need to bring in a
second or or if you only have one and
because you had donated one and the
second one I'm not talking about okay
okay
um okay okay kidneys now sounding like
funny to say kidney garage garage garage
garage garage garage can
yeah one so like we know your eyes at me
wench like we know you think the word
garage is funny like over and over again
wow oh we know we know yes Jackie it's
called relating to another person in a
conversation I know the feeling you're
talking about with kidney because I get
that feeling when I say the word garage
and I know that you get that feeling
because you tell us all the time
because I'm so open and authentic and
honest yes thank you for reminding
everyone English kidney kidney kidney
it sounds fine to me I'm like garage
help
this is okay for help I'm gonna miss you
so much when you go on maternity leave
like it's just it's not the same when
Jax isn't here I know well I'm going on
maternity leave very soon which I am
excited about I'm gonna miss the toast
and I'm gonna miss podcasting with you
but I am excited for like that joie de
Viva will have when we come back
together
that yes like a like a renewed Spirit
between us also I know you didn't do it
on purpose but I'm like eternally
grateful to you for planning your
maternity leave in August because August
is really a dead month for celebrities
for podcasting like our numbers they're
not great right now I'm not gonna lie
like they're they're taking a dip yeah
well no they're they're
we were peaking and now you could tell
if people are on vacation people aren't
like listening on their commute to work
they're listening to the radio while
having like a beer with their friends
they're not listening August
it's always like a slow low month for us
so if we have to take time off I'm glad
it's not like you know February
February's lit you know January is lit
oh so good so August like I'm totally
fine with and you know while you're on
maternity leave like I could take a trip
and what's a better time to take a trip
than August where should I go Central
pay south of France yeah that's where
everyone goes in August I think I should
go okay bye turdy Lou
I don't know like the world is my oyster
now it is wow I've been hanging out with
Olivia too much because that is so
something Olivia would say she loves
like a like a Hallmark card the world is
your oyster like yeah
like a little like colloquialism is that
what it's called like a phrase like a
little quote that you would see she
always says YOLO yeah yeah everything
she's like she'll rationalize every
anything like you'll say oh why did you
do this she'll explain why she did it
and she was like at YOLO you know and
she's so right like you only live once
yeah it's like facts
so funny she's so funny the episode
yesterday was really funny what's also
so funny because we're just like we are
funny comedians we are funny you
podcasted with Olivia yesterday and then
this weekend I podcasted with snitch for
the patreon we did an audio only episode
and it was just like so funny I can't
explain why but she was just cracking me
up she's so
she's so snitchy
you've podcasted with her recently so
like you've experienced it but it was
just hysterical
and I'm excited for everyone to hear it
don't you feel like there's something
going on with the snitch kind of like a
renewal of sorts she's kind of giving
like extra snitchy energy these days
yeah no the snitch I've got and I've
seen her a couple times in like the last
week she's been a wonderful snitch maybe
she's the type of snitch who kind of
blooms in Summer She's a summertime
snitch she would say so you know what
she would say and I would roll my eyes
something about season she said she's in
her season yeah yeah is that like one of
the phrases you hate
no I just like didn't think it made a
lot of sense
interesting I just didn't like I just
feel like seasons change
no that's pretty much they don't last
very long like
so what like what happens when the
season's over
a new season begins but then it's not
her season I just found it faulty
no you're 100 right the fault in our in
our season it was just very limiting I
felt I understand that she was saying it
literally a year and a half ago
and
I feel like she's more in her season now
than she was a year and a half ago so I
feel like maybe she was saying wouldn't
you hope for that what do you hope like
you're constantly becoming even more in
your season not like less time but then
you're not in your season then it's not
a season
yeah I mean I guess if you're the type
of person
who's like you know obsessed with like
facts yeah okay you're right you know
yeah yeah I agree
anyways we do have a good show we've got
some stories for you I missed
commentating on some of the stories that
happened Friday and Monday but I'll be
your girlfriend I'll be okay like Megan
Fox responded to all the weirdos and
what did you think about the tone of her
of her response honestly I liked it
um and it's like so aggressive she was
talking literally to us no I don't think
she was talking to me actually because
I'm not you I was saying like there's
definitely more to the story and I felt
like even though she was being like rude
and technically she was asking for money
from the people she's like she's also
calling weirdos
um so true I like that she did provide
some context like do you guys ever
consider that maybe this makeup artist
like doesn't want her celebrity clients
like having that dynamic between them
that like they paid all her bills she
asked me to put like I said the nail
artist asked for her to post the link
and like what do you say to that
yeah yeah so I I was shocked that she
commented on it I thought it was like
beginning with her to do so but I'm glad
that she did so in a way that had some
character
yeah it was different it was different
yeah it was it wasn't just like you know
everyone worked really hard on this
movie the cast and crew yeah I'm I'm
happy she didn't throw the cast and the
crew under the bus either
yeah so she had something to say and I
enjoyed consuming it
yeah
oh and what was your take on cardi B
oh my God I'm all over the place because
at first I was like you get her cardi me
too like you make an example out of her
[__] around and find out
this is why context is everything yep
everything uh because even though she
said she said splash water on my p word
and then but then apparently she also
said but not on my face so clearly the
girl splashed her and got on her face
but you've seen the video of the girl
she does it and then she's like sorry
sorry I think that she didn't mean to
get on her face she probably turned
around quicker than the girl was
expecting
yeah but also like how do you tell
people to Splash you but not your face
like you can control the level of Splash
like you know once the door is open
floodgates and literally given that she
was the one who opened in the gates like
she doesn't get to have that reaction
yeah you know when I had thought it was
just like a completely unprompted
unprovoked thing I'm like Get Her Like
She's So entitled to that sort of
reaction but context like actually
really made me feel bad for the girl
yeah
okay good I'm glad I got your opinion
yeah so not everything is so cut and dry
yeah I just hope like when an
Entertainer does get
unfairly thrown something out like they
do have that energy me too me too
so it was a good example for like what
type of energy you should have in the
correct situation but it was not the
correct situation correct also I think
her aim was off and she hit a different
girl yes oh the microphone didn't even
hit the girl who threw it you hit
someone else if you're gonna throw
something at someone like you better get
the right girl yeah a hundred percent
like your aim has to be on point mm-hmm
and it wasn't no so those were my
thoughts okay good
so now without further adieu here are
the fast five stories that you need to
know
know are brought to you by game time
buying tickets to your favorite events
should not be stressful game time is the
fast and easy way to buy tickets for all
the sports music comedy and theater near
you with killer deals on last minute
tickets and their best price guarantee
you can stop stressing over the tickets
and start getting hyped for all the fun
you're gonna have
so game time is the place for last
minute ticket deals no longer having to
plan months in advance as you know that
is my least favorite thing game time has
deals on tickets right up to the day of
the event you can also get exclusive
Flash Deals on tickets for football
basketball and baseball concerts comedy
theater and more the game time guarantee
means you'll always get the best price
if you find tickets in the same section
in row for Less game time will credit
you 110 of the difference
it's the fastest growing ticketing app
in the country for a reason get images
of your seats before you buy so you know
exactly what to expect when you arrive
you can buy tickets in a matter of
seconds it's literally two Taps and
you're set and the tickets are sent
directly to your phone so you never have
to dig through your email this is a
great app just to have on your phone at
all times like if you're traveling for
work or for pleasure and you just find
yourself in a new city or you live in a
fabulous City that always has like good
theater concerts events going on make
sure to have the game time app on your
phone you can snag the tickets without
the stress with Game Time download the
game time app create an account and use
code toast for 20 off your first
purchase terms apply again create an
account and redeem code toast for 20 off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price
guaranteed thank you Game Time today's
episode is also brought to you by
Squarespace Squarespace is the
all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online whether you're just starting out
or managing a growing brand Squarespace
makes it easy to create a beautiful
website engage with your audience and
sell anything from products to content
to time it's all in one place and it's
all on your terms so whatever website
you want to create whether it's for a
side hustle of yours you want to start
an e-commerce business a Blog
Squarespace is an amazing resource
because I think the idea of creating a
website can be really intimidating a lot
of people you get fancy degrees to do it
but Squarespace has these really easy to
use templates that will get you a
website up and running that looks like
it was professionally made but you did
it all yourself and it's nobody needs to
know how easy it is they have a ton of
different product features so if you're
looking to sell merch you can easily
sell custom merch and create a passive
income stream that engages your audience
and scales your brand if you're looking
to create an online store you can sell
your products on one of their online
store templates they have flexible
templates they have email campaigns
where you can drive sales and engage
your audience with their email campaigns
you'll easily be able to collect
subscribers on your site and build
connections for repeat business through
regular email updates they also have a
great point of sale so you can sell in
person by connecting a square reader to
the Squarespace app you'll keep your
orders your inventory your customer data
in sync with your online store if your
online store or your website that you're
creating is for e-commerce Squarespace
is the best most organized platform for
online sales for in-person sales it's
really a great
um service and
if you don't know where to start when it
comes to creating a website we highly
recommend Squarespace and if you want to
head to squarespace.com you can get a
free trial when you're ready to launch
go to squarespace.com toast to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain thank you Claudia you're
welcome
yeah first story oh we forgot about our
Han Montana transitions oh
yeah I like that
um
because I like it
our first story is actually some crazy
news that just came out so it is
um actually not the worst thing that we
started this afternoon but a bombshell
lawsuit says that lizzo forced her
dancers to eat bananas from sex workers
vaginas during an Amsterdam trip amongst
other allegations but I do think that is
the most headline grabbing one yeah
three of lizzo's former dancers are
suing the good as hell performer as well
as big girl big touring and Charlene
Quigley for allegedly subjecting them to
endure weight shaming sexually
denigrating behavior and pressuring them
to participate in disturbing sex shows
the plaintiffs Ariana Davis and Crystal
Williams claim in the lawsuit filed on
Tuesday obtained by Page Six that they
eventually were fired uh that they were
eventually fired and the third plaintiff
said that she resigned over lizzo's
stunning Behavior while on a concert
trip with the award-winning Grammy
artist to Amsterdam in February 2023 the
plaintiffs claimed that lizzo invited
them for a night on the town which ended
in the city's red light district the
area is known for sex theaters sex shops
and clubs and bars where nudity is on
Full display the lawsuit States quote
things quickly got out of hand lizzo
began inviting cast members to take
turns touching the nude performers
catching dildos launch from the
performer's vaginas and eating bananas
protruding from the performer's vaginas
no the suit also claims that lizzo
allegedly pressured and goaded Davis
into touching one nude performer's
breasts the plaintiffs claimed that just
a month later lizzo deceived them once
again into attending a nude show thereby
robbing them of the chance of the choice
not to participate
Davis also claims in the lawsuit that at
one point she had no choice but to soil
herself on stage during an excruciating
re-audition fearing the repercussions of
excusing herself to go to the bathroom
eventually lizzo allegedly fired Davis
on the spot after learning Davis had
recorded one of their meetings even
though it was in order to have a copy of
the notes that the artist had provided
Rodriguez resigned shortly thereafter
out of solidarity with Davis and the
disrespect lizzo allegedly showed her
I mean this is like so disturbing and
gross
um and it just came out so I don't think
lizzo's responded yet and I'm sure she
won't just because like again it's like
one of those things where you really
can't say anything because it's like an
ongoing legal matter right
um I do want to say the girl who got
fired for recording
um I can actually see that being I don't
know what they're suing for if it's like
wrongful termination like I do feel like
that's like a big No-No
um and I could see like like lizzo
winning that legal argument
because yeah whatever her reasoning was
like recording and I'm sure she signed
ndas it's like a direct violation of a
contract or whatever but the other stuff
in this uh lawsuit is so deeply
disturbing
um especially as it pertains like
forcing people who work for you and it's
not only people who work for you they're
such a power dynamic between like
celebrity and you know Civility and
there's so many different Dynamics
forcing them to attend like really
disturbing graphic nude lewd I believe
the word is
um performances and like forcing them to
participate is like actually really
traumatizing and this is really
disgusting yeah so what they're suing
for is general and special damages as
well as punitive damages and attorneys
fees and it also says that lizzo and her
manage team treated their performers um
the way that they treated them seemed to
go against everything luzo publicly
stands for privately she weight shames
her dancers and demeans them in ways
that are absolutely demoralizing I think
also weight shaming
um or skinny shaming like maybe if they
were losing weight that's not a good
thing I I couldn't really can't see
lizzo fat shaming someone like that's
literally her whole yeah but they didn't
say fat shaming which makes me like they
said they did say weight shaming so I
feel like it could just be the opposite
yeah like maybe if some of the dancers
just like from being on tour or whatever
like started to lose weight Liz those
whole Aesthetics that she wants to prove
like big girls can be dancers too so if
they're like not corroborating with that
sort of image or they don't have like a
look that she wants right she'll start
shaming them until which is like exactly
what the industry has been doing for
years the opposite but it's still the
same it's wrong it's wrong both ways
it's a core issue
um no I think this is shocking one the
allegations are shocking the banana and
the vagina and the sex
things are wild but also like this is so
incongruous with lizzo's Public Image
like I think yeah Liz those fans and
just
you know
people
are have been really like taken aback by
this even though the news just dropped
it's it's very shocking to hear from so
not lizzo it's not the lizzo you we know
but again we don't know these people
that's so true so I don't know I don't
know yeah
we'll all have it stay in court Brazil
will have an opportunity to defend
herself and maybe make a statement I
feel like she could say
while this is an ongoing legal matter
like everything alleged I feel like a
lot of people would be like this is
completely untrue I look forward to my
day in court yeah especially if that's
what they're going to say in court I
don't know why you couldn't put that out
in a PR statement too yeah yeah but but
is the story like big enough I also
could see people like not caring I feel
like people just like love lizzo and
like whatever no I think it's because I
saw the initial articles in page six and
then like my Instagram just like random
Publications accounts yeah yeah
um
yeah because some of the allegations are
extremely
they're [__] gross yeah
attention grabbing
yeah because it like I feel like
celebrities get sued all the time like
for being like horrible to work with but
the specificity of these
um accusations are so
one specific and be like really
disturbing once you read them yeah yes
and we always get you know like a toxic
workplace right A lot of these like
vague terms which could be really bad
could be really bad or it could just be
like a person's particular experience
yeah and I think when they use big like
those uh buzzwords like toxic workplace
they've kind of lost their meaning yeah
because they never say what it actually
was and we're like okay toxic workplace
like maybe you got yelled at but this is
like actually a toxic workplace yes an
incredible it's specific and also as
stated very different to than the lizzo
that we think we know
this is big if true because sometimes
you hear about someone who's like you
know a mean boss and you're like yeah
they seem like a mean boss well this is
like the conversation and that's their
brand or even like Miranda Lambert
yes oh that's what we were talking about
Miranda Lambert like her situation like
it didn't affect her at all like nobody
pulled her music from country radio like
because she's the bad [__] of country
like it doesn't it makes sense that's
like so Miranda but lizzo's kind of this
queen and like kind of kind of carved
out this whole space in the industry for
you know being different being inclusive
being kind so it it's like I'm trying to
think of an example like Ellen is the
example yes see yes you took the words
right out of my mouth Jackie Ellen is an
example when your brand is kindness and
in turn you end up not evenly not being
kind but being like the nastiest [__]
alive like it's jarring yeah and it
makes the Fallout from the situation a
lot bigger and worse than it would be
yes if it was like you know uh I don't
know Simon Cowell is a hard for us to
please
so true like that's so Simon right
so we will definitely keep tabs on this
story hopefully lizzo will speak out or
the trial will start soon and we'll get
more information but this was just crazy
yeah
are you ready for our next story I am
honestly we have two very sad stories
from yesterday I know I'm like really
upset about Angus Cloud yes English
cloud has passed away
um his family announced yesterday after
uh struggling intensely struggling with
grief following the loss of his father
Conor hickey the week before the 25 year
old actor was found dead in his home on
Monday before that the actor and his
family had reportedly traveled to
Ireland last week to bury their
patriarch the family said it is with the
heaviest heart that we had to say
goodbye to an incredible human today as
an artist a friend a brother and a son
Angus was special to all of us in so
many ways last week he buried his father
and intensely struggled with the loss
the only comfort we have is knowing
Angus is now reunited with his dad who
was his best friend
no this is like so sad Mario sent the
link in our chat and you know when
something shocks you so much like you
can't even read it like yes I knew what
it said but I'm like wait it was not
Computing logistically in my brain I am
so sad and I think that you know any
life loss but someone's so young whose
career had just started like Euphoria is
his first project and he shot to Fame in
every brand wanted to work with him I
think he was like a face of Louis
Vuitton because his character in The
Show for anyone who doesn't watch like
he is like a drug dealer but he's kind
of weirdly like the moral compass of the
show he like looks out for his younger
brother and he's like
he knows what he's doing is wrong but he
just needs the money and he's kind of
like a therapist to a lot of people he's
one of my favorite characters and he's a
lot of people's favorite character and I
think it was
he's not an actor like he's not a
trained actor this was his first job so
I really feel like the character he
played was really similar to the type of
person he was like a very sweet
soft-spoken boy and I don't know any of
that to be like fact or not it's just
the vibe that I get and it just I don't
know I'm like a really this is one of
the saddest things I've that's I've
heard in a really long time yeah I don't
want you for you so I honestly was not
familiar with him but this story
is just so incredibly sad like that's
how profoundly moved he was and
devastated by the loss of his dad I mean
they didn't say cause of death but the
family I feel like they did that they
said the actor was open about his battle
with mental health and hope that his
passing could be a reminder to others
who are struggling that they are not
alone and should not fight this on their
own in silence
I feel like it's a very respectful way
of saying suicide yes
um and that's just so sad it's there's
no other there's really nothing else
like to say other than this is one of
the saddest things and
it's just terrible yeah
I do like he is an active and sort of
kind of main character in Euphoria I
know that Euphoria I believe they said
that the next season not that this
matter is literally at all but like this
is what people talk about yeah um I
believe they said the next season which
I don't even know when it's coming out
but it's like five years in the future
so oh I saw a headline that it was like
not coming out for a few years no no no
no no oh no it's not coming out it's not
coming out for a while and it's also set
in like five years oh okay you'll
probably I probably saw something that
was like new Euphoria set in 2026 or
something right and I thought it meant
it was coming back then understood
um so I feel I really hope that they
like honor him because he was such an
important part and like really just
kind of like the soul of the show so I
hope that they honor him I'm sure that
they will and it'll be really sad to
watch yeah well our next story is also
very sad because Paul Rubens also known
as Pee-wee Herman the actor has died at
the age of 70 after a private bout of
cancer so Paul Reuben the actor best
known for portraying the irrepressibly
joyfully childlike Pee-wee Herman died
Sunday night after a private bout of
cancer
um he wrote in a statement posted to
Instagram after his death please accept
my apology for not going public with
what I've been facing in the last six
years I've always felt a huge amount of
love and respect for my friends fans and
supporters I've loved you all so much
and enjoyed making art for you
can I see a question yes do you know
what I'm gonna say you're going to ask
about his scandal yeah like how do you
reconcile someone's death when they've
done horrible things okay do you know
what he did
child pornography
public masturbation okay so I looked
into it because I was like everyone's
saying the nicest things about Pee-wee
Herman but then I remember but then I
was like but isn't there some like stain
from the past right and I looked into it
and the first thing was uh not public
masturbation he was caught with his like
penis out at a
um like a porn show one of those porn
theaters like so in a place with adults
watching porn he had his penis out which
was so shocking one like it was the 90s
and she was just in congress with him
being this child performer and like
right you know him in his private life
doing something that was more weird than
the character that we know but it was
like a victimless crime that's I mean he
was just attending like a legal thing
and had his wiener out but I've kind of
remembered the story as him being in
like a movie theater with his pecker out
with other people around but no it was a
porn house yeah so in 2002 he was also
charged with one misdemeanor count of
possessing material depicting children
engaged in sexual conduct a charge that
was later dropped with the actor
pleading guilty to a charge of obscenity
instead okay so then I saw that child
pornography thing and it it was like
cartoon uh images or cartoons that were
like vintage like they're from 30 years
ago it wasn't like active child
pornography like we think about it and I
don't even know what do you mean
cartoons not cartoons like um editorial
hold on I was just reading about it I
know what you mean Pee-Wee Herman's
Scandal this is what it said
I just want to speak correctly on it
yeah yeah
I feel like the first one you wouldn't
get arrested for today like having your
penis out at a sex show yeah and they
weren't the charges were dropped got it
so okay in 2001 please search his home
in the Hollywood Hills they see these
boxes of materials that his spokesperson
characterized as vintage erotica the
lawyer said the charges of possessing
images of child pornography were untrue
and without Merit and his publicist said
the handful of images came from more
than ten thousand vintage magazine C's
from the actors home some of which were
three decades old
the charges were dropped in 2004 when he
pleaded guilty to a lesser obscenity
charge so it's not like child
pornography it's like as we think of it
today it's like these children are
exploit like yeah no I think of like
Mark Sailing who had like you know files
and files of homemade terrible
exploitive nude children yeah not that
not squeaky clean I don't know what the
images were and there's all like there's
so many things of like Char there's
charges against him charges dropped when
the charges are dropped I'm not in it
like can we not move on from a question
that's a good question I don't know it's
a little dicey and
I don't know
actually totally random like literally I
don't know this is not a good tangent
but I was just thinking about prison
last night I watched um jelly roll has a
documentary on Hulu and I really like
obviously I know him because he's
country but like I don't really know his
story at all and it was fascinating I
highly recommend the documentary he um
and like I know that he has like these
incredibly devout obsessed fans like I
didn't really understand why
um and his whole thing is is addiction
he was you know a pretty big drug addict
and drug dealer and he was in and out of
juvie and you know adult prison for like
you know the formative years of his life
and he finally got his act together and
just kind of focused everything he was
focusing on drugs putting into music
um and he talked a lot about how like he
trades one Vice for another and how like
he talked about his weight actually
really openly and how like food is
definitely one of the things he traded
for drugs and like it's better but he's
now obese and like his words not mine
um and like is that healthy yeah yeah
but he's like it's better than you know
crack
it was really an interesting documentary
I actually think he would like it and
now I feel like I understand because it
doesn't feel like he kind of came out of
left field into the music space with
like all these fans yeah
but so like addiction and Recovery is so
his beat and I think that's like those
are the people who are really impacted
by his music and he it was actually
really amazing he likes you know spends
so much time and money while he's out on
the road visiting um rehab facilities
and juvenile like delinquent centers I
don't know if they still call them that
but
um and he brings them food and like if
they have any passions like he bought
this girl a guitar just so she could
like Focus her energy on that instead of
you know like
being with the wrong crowd it was a
really good documentary okay I'll check
it out and he was talking about I'm
sorry this is I remember why I thought
of it he was basically saying he's so
much guilt for the things he did that
ended him in PR ended up in prison for
him like yeah he stole drugs but then he
had like armed robbery and like he hurt
a lot of people
um and he feels like he really can't
move on and that's why he does all these
things I think he feels this like
immense amount of guilt and he never
lives in the present because he's so
stuck in the past he's like I don't know
how or when like people can forgive me
and like I can forgive myself for the
things that I did and he's like clearly
a good person he just like was a
troubled teen who hurt people
um and that's that's what it reminded me
of because it's like at what point
do you you know move on the premier
Carmen thing is different because I feel
like when you really look into it you're
right they're not like
they're not the crazy like they're not
it's it's not like especially
considering what we see in here today
and especially out of Hollywood but
um I was just looking more like so he
was fine a hundred dollars for the and
he did a three years probation and
agreed to register as a sex offender so
yeah
um okay wait now now I want to backtrack
a little bit I feel like being
registered as a sex offender is like no
small thing this is what he said at the
time he said I'm glad the prosecutors
finally dismissed the child pornography
charge without me or the taxpayers
having to pay for a costly circum
circus-like trial I'm disappointed any
part of my collection was ever deemed
inappropriate taking responsibility by
calling a few images in this collection
obscene and paying a hundred dollar fine
seemed like the sanest way to make it
end he said I don't want anyone for one
second to think that I am titillated by
images of children it's not me you can
say lots of things about me and you
might the public may think I'm weird
they may think I'm crazy or anything
that anyone wants to think about me
that's all fine as long as one of the
things you're not thinking about me is
that I'm a pedophile because that's not
true
okay but he's a sex offender
yeah that was a part of a plea deal in
order to not
go to trial anyways
like I said interesting
context is key but I him being a sex
offender definitely changes my
perspective a little bit
well your perspective was like really
negative before yes yes
who said horrible things
in the on the scale of horrible things
this is bad but not even close to like
some of the other things we see you're
correct yeah
interesting
but I also like I don't know what the
the bar is work no the images I want to
know agent I don't want to know
rest in peace rest in peace
Pee-wee Herman
I used to [__] so hard with people I
actually but I also feel like since he's
Patrick not a lot of people are talking
about all that stuff no that's what so
funny because I knew about it and this
morning when we were on the plane Ben
like was reading a newspaper weirdly and
he was like PB Herman died I'm like oh
my god do you live under a rock and then
the article also mentioned his crimes
have been was like wait I didn't know
that why is like nobody talking about
that why is everybody praising him and
I'm like no it's a good question
yeah
I'm not sure
I don't have all these now he's gone so
let him rest in peace rest in peace sir
or rip peewee rip rip are you ready for
our next story
is it our next story that's brought to
you by JS Health vitamins a science
focused vitamin and wellness brand that
provides targeted formulas to help you
meet your personal health goals it's
created using the highest quality
ingredients backed by research it's made
in Australia and created by expert
nutritionist Jessica sepel and they have
a formula for all of your needs from
skin to digestion stress sleep hair
growth and more Aussies are globally
renowned for their High supplement
standards and it is really shown with
these vitamins the detox and deep bloat
is their tried and true best seller it's
designed to reduce bloating and support
natural detoxification based on
traditional use
it's uh begin from the friendly formula
it's made with turmeric milk thistle
fennel and it's made out of
research-backed supplement dose to
support liver function and promote
healthy digestion it is a Formula that
can honestly give you comfort and
confidence very quickly the advanced
magnesium from JS Health vitamins
contain three forms of bioavailable
magnesium it's carefully designed to
support muscle relaxation energy
production and nervous system
functioning that's the magnesium plus
from JS Health it's one of their best
sellers as well Jazz health is just a
great brand with really high standards
for their supplements so if you're
concerned at all about what supplements
you're taking and what the ingredients
might be in there check out JS Health
their vitamins again are science focused
their Wellness brand that provide
targeted formulas to help you meet your
personal health goals and they are made
with the highest quality ingredients
that are all backed by research go to
jshealthvitamins.com toast and use code
toast for 20 off your order or your
first subscription order so that's
jshealthvitamins.com toast code toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by article summer is on its way have you
been dreaming up ideas for your outdoor
space and how to make the most of it
well the best thing about summer is
getting to do all of your favorite
indoor things outside like sharing meals
watching movies falling asleep on the
sofa we all know everything is just
better Alfresco so articles curated
catalog of outdoor furniture is here to
help you do all of your favorite things
this summer they've got everything you
need to really make things your own from
outdoor sofas to dining sets to Decor
their flexible range of styles means
that you can do more with the space that
you've got and it's um the ultimate open
concept area so if you have so much if
you have a backyard uh balcony a Terrace
whatever your outdoor situation is
there's so much potential so why not
make your outdoor space really work for
you article believes in delightful
design for every home thanks to their
online only model they have really
delightful pricing as well their curated
assortment of mid-century modern Coastal
industrial scandi and boho designs make
furniture shopping simple their team of
designers are all about finding the
perfect balance between style quality
and price they're dedicated to
thoughtful craftsmanship that stand the
test of time they offer fast affordable
shipping across the US and Canada I can
attest to that because Jackie has some
beautiful outdoor furniture at her
stunning home and I was there when it
was delivered and it was actually so
simple and so easy they were like really
communicative it was like not a
stressful thing
their customer care team is there when
you need them to make sure your
experience is smooth and stress-free
article is offering our listeners 50 off
their first purchase of 100 or more to
claimbusite article.com toast and the
discount will be automatically applied
at checkout that's article.com toast for
50 off your first purchase of 100 or
more thanks Claudia yeah well
um our next story update BB rexa
confirms a breakup with her boyfriend
kian's Safari after the body shaming
text these two are by the way body
shaming text is misleading yeah I agree
wait I have some thoughts so BB Rex so
reportedly gave London constant Growers
an emotional update on her relationship
on Friday before performing atmosphere
she asked the audience members to help
her she said I just went through a
breakup so I might get a little
emotional
I can't blame myself for getting lost in
the promise of you and I can't can't
blame you for leaving later in the
concert she teared up over a fan sign
telling her that she was enough
she also detailed her plans to look for
a new boyfriend at the heaven nightclub
the outlet reported e-news reported on
Monday
Monday I can't blame him for leaving
either if anybody ever screenshotted my
[__] personal text messages like you
bet your ass will never talk to you
again you don't think she broke up with
him
she said I don't blame you for leaving
well that wasn't her lyric
oh oh I'm sorry I thought that was like
part of her monologue before the song Oh
no that's her song atmosphere but yeah
that is that is confusing
but but you know what like these two are
not for each other a relationship cannot
survive that if we don't have a boundary
between private and public especially
when you're a celebrity good day sir but
I was in the car yesterday the radio was
on and like some radio hosts were
talking about this story and I was
actually interested to hear what they
were going to say because I feel like
they don't ever like you know say
anything they're probably no they don't
have hot takes they like regurgitate
like you shouldn't talk about a woman's
body and like of course you shouldn't
but did you read the text message
because it's much more layered right so
I was like I wonder what they're gonna
say like are they just gonna be like
corny be like bad Kian
but one of the guys said was like listen
if your wife or your girlfriend ever
asks you have I put on weight or how do
I look you just lie you just said you
look great you say no I don't see a
weight game and that's like and the
female host was like yeah some she's
like yeah I love honesty but sometimes
like what good is it and I was just like
that's bad advice am I crazy I would
never ask that question unless I truly
wanted good answer
so if I'm gonna say that and you're
gonna lie to me like I'm gonna be
vulnerable and you're lying like no I
actually what are women stupid like I
don't know I think this guy what
this Bebe Rex's boyfriend was an
impossible situation either he lies or
he says the truth and then he's like you
know blasted for body shaming her in the
text we had seen that she had asked him
yes yes that's the whole like so
honestly I understand why this guy is
just like just say they look good like
whatever right no then like no you need
to be honest like only if somebody asks
don't offer that information up of
course no we're saying if somebody asks
or like you know you're getting ready
for an event like do I look good I you
shouldn't say anything other than yes
yeah I'm just at a place in my life now
where like I know if I look good and I
know if I look bad like Ben's opinion
truly means nothing to me like that's
true sometimes I get dressed he's like I
don't think that looks right I'm like oh
cool you're wrong like I'm good well I
guess like if the question was framed
like I've gained weight have you noticed
that's just why would anyone ask that
question yeah no it's it's never going
to end well no never
stay away from women who ask that
question
because it's never going to end well I
don't think like blanket lying should be
your go-to like relationships are meant
to be like places of honesty and
vulnerability no but some right I yeah
no I agree
but it doesn't work out
no I know Kian got in trouble
and it sounded like he he couched his
whole sentence with love and you're
beautiful to me and
even though he was answering honestly
like it's not like he said in a mean way
yeah that like that situation with Bibi
it kind of backfired I actually was
really surprised at how many people on
the internet were giving their takes and
like we're actually critically thinking
and like looking into context clues
because I feel like we see that and
everyone's just like oh [__] this guy
but like if you gave it like five
minutes of thought
you were able and like you thought about
it critically like I I think there was
enough context in the text to like make
an argument for his side and I was
actually really surprised at the amount
of people I saw like just giving their
opinions on it not just giving that sort
of regurgitated like oh man never
comment on a woman's body like that
because that's not what was happening
here you shouldn't comment on a woman's
body but let's not use that that doesn't
apply here yeah but like if you're asked
a question like don't you also have to
get an answer it's not it's rude not to
right so either you're commenting on a
woman's body or you're a liar which are
both or you're not answering your
question and that's rude yeah
it's yeah I don't know it's interesting
it's a no-win situation so I understand
why like you know the guy would just be
like I'll just say what I'm out I know
she wants to hear
by the way I did figure that these two
were broken up I didn't think that they
could make it back after that so this is
not news to me no it's not I didn't even
think about it I was like yeah duh
are you ready for a fit and final story
is there a final Story by Taylor Swift
no did you see the news that like I
don't know uh it came out that since her
U.S tour is about to end this weekend is
the last leg in La
um that she gave out five million
dollars worth of bonuses to everyone
um who works on the tour Each truck
driver got a Bonus of a hundred thousand
dollars I saw the truck drivers but I
didn't see the sum total of five million
yeah I thought that was pretty sick like
my queen continues to slay yeah but they
did a great job and those trucks really
trucked on time every time every well
hopefully this last one let's not jinx
it but by the way they're already there
California to California they'll be fine
right right right right no that was
really cool like she's a queen yeah she
is a queen
um I'm gonna miss seeing all the clips
and stuff even though it's it's petered
out and like Heim just isn't doing it
for me
so it's okay I think the LA Clips will
be fun to watch I forget who I was just
having this conversation with but now
we're in our era of Beyonce Clips like
now my engine remember how you're saying
you were like I feel like Beyonce's tour
isn't like getting as much like you're
right hype as Taylor so I'm like just
wait till they switch continents because
now all of my the people that I follow
are going to see Beyonce I'm getting all
of these like viral videos from accounts
I don't follow of Blue Ivy and like and
the outfits and everything and so now
we're just swapping yeah me too like I
100 you were totally right
um but I was just having this
conversation with someone I can't
remember who but like I find it so
shocking that like I never really took
to him because they're three sisters
they're Jewish sisters
there's so much like about them that I
should deeply relate to and just
automatically stand for that reason and
the fact that they're Taylor's best
friends maybe it's deep rooted in
jealousy that like like it should be me
Taylor's gonna have a best friend that
should be me holding your hand but I
never really got on board hard
I agree and I feel like I have the
potential to like their music I love
that one song The Wire yeah
so it wasn't a fade to come play yeah
but I agree I no thank you no I just
it's so bizarre and I could never I
don't I'm not into any of it
maybe but I wish I'm truly the best
they've been such good friends to Taylor
's been very good to them
I don't know what I'm trying to think I
don't think it's like jealousy
it might be jealous sort of like
projection yeah because you're a bunch
of Jewish sisters you're just like not
doing what I would do maybe it's like
internalized anti-Semitism honestly
I don't know what the [__] it is why
don't I scan I don't think it is because
I don't associate them with Judaism
necessarily maybe that's the problem
maybe they're not just enough no they're
so proudly Jewish I know you don't
follow them but they're like I follow
them on Tick Tock they're oh wait they
do this little Hanukkah series like
they're proud juices like they everyone
knows that they're Jewish their original
band name was like the bagel [__]
like nobody like lecheim yeah right like
they're totally proud Jews I love that
about them okay so I don't know what it
is
I think it's internalized anti-Semitism
for real no I don't think it is
no by the way I don't either there's
something there there's something yeah
there's a block we should ex we should
explore that in therapy there's a block
yeah okay our fifth and final story I
actually think this is going to be an
interesting conversation starter
because it's layered Love is Blind Alum
Nick Thompson so he was on season three
he got engaged to Danielle remember them
she went to dance and he like wanted to
not
um he revealed that he is on the brink
of homelessness because nobody will hire
him in the wake of the dating show as
he's slamming the exploitative Netflix
for paying him just seven dollars and 14
cents an hour with no residuals so
let me take it from the top former Love
is Blind star Nick Thompson has revealed
he's at the risk of losing his home
after struggling to find a job in the
wake of his 2021 appearance on Love is
Blind
for which he said he was paid just 7 14
an hour when you break it down because
they were waiting for 24 hours because
he was he said he was only paid ten
thousand dollars for 10 weeks of filming
and that there has been zero discussion
about residual pay despite the ongoing
success of Love is Blind
um he said when you know this is
actually interesting timing with the
strike yes it's it's a strike related
combo in Bethany Frankel has also been
getting in on this combo about reality
stars and residuals so he said when you
think about the amount of money that's
being made and the way that it's the
path for future seasons and the fact
that anyone can go on and watch me and
I'm going to be homeless I lost my job
last November I'm having an incredibly
hard time finding a new one he said he
said I burned through my savings that
cashed out my 401k I've got two months
left in the bank to pay my mortgage I
can't get a job because people don't
take me seriously I was a VP in software
for five years so it's not like I don't
have track record or experience or
success he also described feeling like
he was being kept prisoner during his
time in the social experiment and
believes that he and others uh were
manipulated by producers and
psychologists
shed light on the brutal reality of
filming Love is Blind he alleged that
producers are in control of you 24 hours
a day quote you are filming 18 to 20
hours a day and that doesn't necessarily
mean you're always going to be on TV but
you're milked from the moment you get
there in the morning and you're milked
all the way up until you leave then when
you go home at the end of the day you're
locked in your hotel room without a key
without your wallet without money
without ID you are literally held
captive like a prisoner and there's
absolutely no reason that you shouldn't
be considered an employee when you're
technically under the control of your
employer for 24 hours a day since
appearing on Love is Blind he's gone to
co-launch the unscripted cast advocacy
Network which helps provide mental
health and legal support to pass present
and future reality stars
his comments come just weeks after
Bethenny Frankel called for reality TV
Reckoning amid the ongoing saga a SOG
sag
and wga Strikes she argued that reality
stars should receive residuals for the
shows that they appear in and that they
should unionize you know what I feel
like this conversation is actually
really interesting and if anything
seeing like the the um
the negative we know so many reality
star success stories but we really don't
hear about the ones that don't go as
well and it really makes um an argument
for a union for uh reality stars and I
had followed this because there's
another element to this I had followed
he's always coming up on my Tick Tock
making videos about his his stuff and he
ended up I think having beef with Nick
vial yeah because Nick vile talked about
a lot of the stuff that um what's his
name the other oh he's also name is Nick
right Nick yeah Nick Nick vial talked
about a lot of the stuff that Nick was
posting on social media and basically
was like
too bad okay I saw like months ago that
they had beef about yes something and I
think it was about oh I think it was
about like maybe Mental Health
yes exploitation of like people's and
producers on reality TV yeah and
producers kind of controlling you and
manipulating you and I think Nick was
like you know
my words not his like manipulation being
manipulated is like a choice like you
know you should be mentally strong
enough to not you know which is like
kind of like a crazy thing to say I wish
I could recall better what I saw but I
feel like there was also the argument
being made of like if you have these
mental health issues you should not go
on a reality show by the way and you
shouldn't and I think that they a lot of
the shows like The Bachelor they do like
fake ass psych evaluations for people
because they don't they want the crazy
no sorry that's the I'm sorry I don't
mean crazies I'm sorry that was not
that's not what I meant they want the
people who can be easily manipulated and
can maybe have a breakdown because they
think that's entertaining and it makes
good TV so those psych evaluations are
fake as hell like they don't actually
they don't say oh this person's not
stable let's kid they say oh this
person's not stable get them in yeah
yeah they're they're actively seeking
people yeah they couldn't uh manipulate
so when you think about like how reality
stars don't have health insurance
reality stars don't get residuals like
the amount of people who go back and
watch like old episodes of like the
bachelor like all these things they're
really it is an argument for a union I
actually think it's a good idea yeah I
think it's a good argument and I feel
like this entire time we've been talking
about the strike it's like what about
the reality TV piece yeah we've been
talking about that and that's kind of
just been like the gray area where it's
like oh they can still film and they can
still promote and everything
um but
I think for some reality stars
they feel exploited
yeah and we just are never talking about
those people we're always talking about
like current reality stars successful
realities because there is someone who
want to launch their own business there
is a lot to gain from going on reality
TV too right like you could argue
someone's going back and watching this
guy next episode so then they're gonna
follow him on Instagram which is a form
of currency that you can monetize like I
there is an argument but I don't think
it's strong enough like
yeah I could see how you know for the
girls especially I think it's much
easier to have a career afterwards I
think I keep bringing up the bachelor
but because it's like it's the show
that's produced the most reality stars
in my opinion and I think a lot of the
guys really struggle
money-wise afterwards it's not as easy
yeah but also think about like the
Housewives
yeah yeah but I feel like but that's a
show of affluent people that's true but
they're also jeopardizing their standing
yeah they are but those are people who
like
who without the show still have a house
you know what I mean not always and in a
lot and this is going to be a very like
you know misogynistic thing but in a lot
of the situ a lot of the housewives it's
like more traditional the man makes the
money for sure but that shouldn't
dictate whether you got paid
appropriately of course of course of
course of course of course of course but
also I think housewives are more
appropriately
first of all I think the starting rate
is like a ten thousand dollars a season
which is what they were making on Love
is Blind but you don't have to surrender
your ID and your wallet 24 7. and yeah
be in a situation like that but also
with the show Like Love is Blind it's
like you don't know who's going to
go all the way get does quote unquote
deserves the biggest paycheck contribute
to most to the storyline so everybody
gets paid the same weather you know
you're a star or not but I guess if you
don't get engaged
and you don't go into the next phase you
probably don't get ten thousand dollars
for that right like your paycheck I
think is directly correlated to the
amount of time you spend on the show and
if you don't make it out of the pods
with a partner your time is up yeah
maybe it's like a thousand dollars an
episode actually
or it might be per week
yeah
because he said 10 000 for 10 weeks
because he made it all the way to the
end to the wedding but after I think
it's four weeks in the Pod or maybe even
two yeah no there's definitely like a
conversation to be had here like with
residuals and also like on a 24-hour
show like you should be paid better
um but you shouldn't also expect to go
on one episode of one season of reality
TV and that that's gonna like cover you
for the rest of your life you're still
gonna need to work so he's still gonna
have this issue of like people don't
take it seriously and he's getting
residuals but he'd be getting residuals
okay is that enough to live the
residuals from Love Is Mine which is how
many people on the show how many people
are even watching it past that big first
boom right and again like we've said
like the streamers would have to release
their numbers in order to like
um
figure out how much to pay people for
residuals and the argument has been
being made that those numbers aren't
what people think they are
yeah no I think like if he got residuals
it would be helpful but it wouldn't
solve his problem no not at all and the
expectation that you go on a show and
get residuals for the rest of your life
that are going to like keep your house
for 10 episodes of the show working
actors who aren't like super famous but
have been you know working their whole
lives they get residuals I follow a
bunch of people on Tick Tock who are
like working actors and they always are
opening up their sag residuals like from
the mail on Tick Tock it's actually
really interesting and they have like 20
30 40 50 projects from the last however
many years that that kid that's their
salary residuals over you know for the
rest of their life because it's multiple
projects everyone talks about the
friends residuals it wasn't just 10
episodes that they did it's well yeah
that that's like the one percent in Sag
that like is really not applicable here
I think it's like 99 of sag members I
don't reach the minimum salary to get
health insurance which is twenty six
thousand dollars a year
got it it might not be 99 but like it's
an insane amount and so that's who this
this strike is really for it's not for
Tom Cruise you know he's fine no no I
didn't think but the Tom Cruise not Tom
Cruise himself but like people like
Thomas are standing in solidarity with
the strikers
um I actually read that like Matt
because I I saw like a bunch of people
like threads and stuff people um calling
out certain celebrities who like haven't
shown up physically at the picket line
um and then people were just like
arguing in the comment section and I was
just reading it
um I think it was Matt Damon and Ben
Affleck have been uh secretly paying the
rents of a lot of sag members you know
who are either you know production
coordinators cameramen like you know
actual cast and crew
um and secretly paying their rents which
I thought was really interesting that's
really nice but they haven't shown up at
the picket line was the point right and
then people were arguing like well it's
a security concern you can't Leonardo
DiCaprio can't just stand in the street
right and that's why you never know the
whole story in context it's everything
it's true but I do think that a reality
Union and isn't the worst idea yeah and
especially for like even shows like
Vanderpump Rules like people really are
always going back and watching those and
it should be
you should be compensated yeah no so
it's fair and that is really sad for him
I know but I'm surprised we have like
more people haven't come out if you
think about how many reality shows like
have like a blip of Fame everyone's
obsessed with it for 35 seconds like too
hot to handle you know
um I think a lot of the girls end up
becoming like social successful social
media creators but I think that's really
hard for the guys yeah some of them like
do okay I mean especially if you can
like go back to your old job and do a
little bit of social it's all good but
I feel bad that he's having such a hard
time me too and I think he's got a good
uh he makes a good argument yeah he does
and he's got Bethany on his side and
she's a strong force yeah no if I want
anybody on my side like because I'm in
an argument with someone like I want
Bethany on my son totally
good stories Jax thanks oh nice long
episode today sorry it was so delayed
guys thank you for your patience
um again love you dearly I don't know
we'll wrap it up so we can get it up
right yeah we will Jackie will wrap it
up condom so we can get it up
penetration condom
condom
um thank you guys so much for listening
to The Chosen Monday Morning Show where
we deliver the past five stories you
need to know everybody through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so at Spotify
iTunes Stitch or public radio I already
castbox all the places where we listen
to podcasts by NASA toast leave a five
star review about a beautiful stunning
and wickedly talented we are hope you
guys have an amazing day and we'll see
you tomorrow love you bye